[موسيقى]
رغم اختلاف الاهداف والازمنه والاماكن
تتفق انظمه التعليم على اهميه الامتحانات
كوسيله تقييم للمعرفه ما يجعلها مصدر قلق
دائم للطلبه ان لم نقل انها ذلك الوحش
الذي يطارد احلامهم بنيل الامتيازات
الاكاديميه لكن كيف نشات هذه الوسيله
يعتقد ان الامتحانات وجدت منذ عهود طويله
وان المعلمين اختبروا حفظه طلابهم شفهيا
لكن نشاتها الرسميه قد تعود لنحو 2100 عام
حيث كانت المدارس الصينيه تقيم طلابها من
خلال جعلهم يربطون مجموعه اقواس معا بشكل
صحيح وسريع كامتحان مهاري يمكن للطالب
الناجح فيه فقط الاستمرار بالدراسه كذلك
كانت الصين القديمه اول من ادخل مفهوم
الاختبار لاختيار موظفي الدوله حيث اجرت
اسره سوي في عام 605 للميلاد الامتحان
الامبراطوريه كشرط للتوظيف وهو النظام
الذي لم يلغى حتى عام
1905 بعد الصين في عام
1806 اتبعت انجلترا نظام الامتحانات
لتقييم المرشحين المؤهلين للخدمه المدنيه
كذلك بدات في عام
1853 الامتحانات التنافسيه لاختيار
الموظفين وكانت الاختبارات تجرى انذاك
بلندن في اغسطس من كل عام في وقت لاحق تم
تكييف نظام التقييم مع التعليم واصبح اداه
شائعه لتقييم الطلاب بنهايه الفصل الدراسي
ففي عام
1858 اصدرت المدارس الانجليزيه بالتعاون
مع جامعتي
اختبارات موحده للطلبه فيما كانت جامعه
مومباي الهنديه قد اجرت قبل عام من ذلك
اول اختبار للقبول الجامعي حيث تم تقديمه
في عام
1857 ليصبح سبيل الوحيد لدخول الجامعات
الى ان تم استبداله في عام
1940 بامتحان اول انديا للحصول على القبول
الجامعي
تزامنا مع ذلك انشات الحكومه اليابانيه
امتحانات للقبول بالمدارس العامه
اليابانيه
لتبديل في عام
1941 بامتحان القبول بالمدرسه العليا ثم
تحول الاختبار للقبول الجامعي في عام
في الرابع عشر من ديسمبر عام
1958 اجرت جامعه كيمرج اول اختبار موحد
على مستوى بريطانيا وشارك فيه طلبه
المدارس والكنائس وكان يضم تخصصات عده
كاللغات والرياضيات والتاريخ والجغرافيا
شهدت العمليه التعليميه تحولات كثيره
لاحقا واصبح في كل بلد تقريبا امتحان قبول
موحد لكن اهم التغيرات جاءت على يد
البروفيسور الالماني هنري فيشل الذي كان
قد انضم لجامعه انديانا الامريكيه في عام
1961 حيث اقترح استبدال الامتحانات
الفصليه
تقييم على مدار العام وهو النظام الذي
تبنته العديد من المدارس
والجامعات مع ثوره التكنولوجيا العصريه
تطورت الامتحانات وتطورت اساليبها واصبح
بامكان الطالب اجراء امتحان عن بعد بواسطه
جهاز محوسب وخط انترنت من اي مكان في
العالم لكن ما لم يتغير هو تلك الرهبه
التي ترافق موعد كل جلسه اختبار مهما كان
حجمه
[موسيقى]